welcome back to the next session thanks
for joining us uh so you know for our
speaker for this session uh you know
we're thrilled to have drew fidenberg
joining us from mit to tell us about his
work on uh learning and equilibrium
refinement so i'll let drew take it away
thanks dylan um
as dylan said i'm gonna talk about
learning equilibrium refinements
um but before i get to that
i thought it would be helpful to do a
little bit of
review to set the stage and then i'll
get
to the new stuff in the second half of
talk
so just to give them on the same page
remind you that there's now quite an
extensive literature
on way that nash equilibrium
in a
game
can arise the longer result of a
learning process at least if the game is
a one-shot simultaneous move game a game
played in the normal form
you probably also know
that
given an extensive form game we can
associate a normal form game
and the definition of nash equilibrium
applies unchanged to games in extensive
form
however
the learning foundation of equilibrium
does change
because if agents are playing a game
repeatedly
they needn't learn the consequences of
deviating from the equilibrium path if
you always played left you never see
what your opponents would do if you
played right so if agents are purely
myopic
then learning only justifies the weaker
concept of self-confirming equilibrium
not nash equilibrium let alone
refinements
and you know i'm not here to um
disparate self-confirming equilibrium
it's been useful in many areas of
economics
uh
experimental economics but also macro
our own economy history
but in other applications we'd like to
use more restrictive concepts such as
nash equilibrium
or even one of the equilibrium
refinements
so let's let's talk about when we'd
expect learning to lead to nash
equilibrium or refinement in an
extensive form game let's just say
please um feel free to interrupt any
time i only have 32 slides
so um
probably won't need the full 45 minutes
so
suppose our agents are
are playing
according to some fixed strategy profile
not saying what it is or why but that
they only use that profile typically
they experiment at rate one over t
by which i mean that each period t
there's a probability one over t that
the agents do something other than what
their strategy prescribes they
experiment with other actions sort of
mechanistically or as a heuristic
well
we can look at all the
information sets that have positive
probability under this fixed profile
so they're hit almost every period
and if people at those nodes experiment
at rate one over t
then any information set that can be
reached
with a single deviation from the
equilibrium path or the path of a
strategy profile are reached infinitely
often
because one over t has an infinite sum
so that means that if agents played this
profile over and over and experimented
in this way
then the agents who move on the path of
play
would eventually come to have correct
beliefs about what would happen if they
deviated from the equilibrium path so if
they're maximizing their their payoff
given their
beliefs and they know what would happen
if they deviated and they're choosing
not to deviate we have a nash
equilibrium so that's the first hint
into how learning might lead to
equilibrium we need some experimentation
with these off path actions in
particular we need people to experiment
at rate one over t
but note if we want equilibrium
refinements like say
backwards induction
then
we need to have more information further
down the tree than that
and if agents experiment at rate one
over t
that needn't lead to correct beliefs
at nodes that take two or more
deviations to reach
because one over t squared has a finite
sum so as in this picture suppose our
profile is that one mostly is playing a
both probably one over t
one experiments with b
and t each period mostly plays d because
she thinks that's the best action but
probably one over t she experiments with
c
well then one will end up playing b
infinitely often so one will learn what
two is doing
and two is basically almost always
playing d and one learns that and
suppose that given that two is playing d
one wants to play a that's fine so we
have a nash equilibrium
but why is two playing d
well two's playing d because of what she
thinks player 3 is doing
will to learn what player 3 is doing
well not with this particular
mechanistic specification of play
because player 3 is only reached in any
period with probably one over t squared
so that's only a finite sum so player
two will only get a finite collection a
finite number of observations of threes
play and if two started out really
pretty sure that clear is playing a
certain way
this
finite set of data
might not be enough to
change her mind and lead her to the
correct beliefs
okay well
so
with this
one over t rule
player two won't learn three's play of
course one over two was sort of
arbitrary the idea was we wanted
experimentation
but we think we also
like it to vanish asymptotically so
there's no long run average cost suppose
we replace these one over t's with one
over root t
well now
the probability of player three has
reached one over t so that happens
infinitely often okay
so that sort of raises a question how
much experimentation do we think that
the players will do
and what experiment and what actions do
we think they'll experiment with
so we could
make up some assumptions or axioms how
people experiment and that's um
one approach but my talk today is going
to be about a body of work that takes a
different approach
where
instead of making assumptions about the
way the players experiment
we're going to derive experimentation
from discounted dynamic programming
and we'll find
that when patients are patient they do
in fact experiment enough to rule out
non-nash equilibria
and moreover
by considering which experiments are
used more often we can derive
equilibrium refinements restrictions on
which nash equilibrium arise
okay
so
it'll be kind of like the classic
equilibrium or finance literature but as
we'll see it's not the same it's not the
same restrictions as those that have
been developed in the classic literature
which is maybe not that surprising
because the classic
literature on equilibrium refinements
refining nash equilibrium sort of
developed without any reference at all
to any mechanism by which players might
get to an equilibrium in the first place
and certainly no consideration of
learning because so that's uh the the
overview
and let me um get into the
the model and results now so the talks
the um
different papers i'm going to tell you
about share a lot of features in common
and be some small details that differ
from paper to paper but i'll try and
point out as we go
so in all these papers
we'll have agents
who are bayesian
and they believe they're facing a fixed
steady state distribution of opponents
play
but they don't know what that steady
state is
and they're going to play an extensive
game repeatedly and each time it's
played they'll observe the terminal note
of the game
they'll tell them all the moves that
were made in the game but it won't tell
them what their opponents would have
done
at information sets that weren't reached
and then players are bayesian they get
some data they'll update their beliefs
now it's not just there's only one
player one playing one player two then
they'd be playing a repeated game
and it's not what we want we want
players to learn how to play this
extensive game and not being involved in
a meta or repeated game so we're going
to have a large population of agents in
each player role as is done in lab
experiments and the players are
anonymously and randomly matched to play
each other each
time period
so because you're never going to see
your current partner again
you have no particular reason to change
your play now to change how your partner
plays in future matches with yet other
partners
and
i said our players update their beliefs
well of course there's problems updating
beliefs if you see a zero probability
event so we're going to assume that our
players have non-doctrinaire partners
they have a
prior over prevailing distribution
opponent's play that's represented by a
smooth density function
time in this model is discrete and
doubly infinite
in this overlapping generations
each period some agents leave the
population and are replaced
agents
are trying to maximize their expected
discounted lifetime payoff
against the unknown distribution of
opponents play
so they face dynamic programming
problems
and
the game is finite this is the stage
game there's discounting so
there's a solution to these
um
dynamic programming problems
and since our agents are expected
utility maximizers it's without loss of
generality to let them use deterministic
policies so for any given history
um
you have a deterministic choice of
strategy so what does that mean so it
means
you're a new agent you play in a certain
way you've played once and you've seen
your partner play left is what you do
next time and your policy says for every
sequence
of
observations you could have had what do
you do in the next match
okay so importantly
we could have a population of player
ones all using the same policy
that doesn't mean they'll all take the
same actions or play the same strategy
each period because if they've met
different opponents
and observed different outcomes they
will then
play different strategies with the same
policy
okay that clear
can't see anyone but hopefully you'll
speak up if there's any questions
okay that's good
the state of the system is the mass of
agents with each possible history
new players have no history
some players played once and saw a
particular terminal node z
some played twice and saw the note z z
prime and so on okay importantly
because we have a continuum of agents
the random matching process of matching
up the player ones and player twos is
deterministic if half the player ones
have a certain history and a third to
player twos have a certain history then
one sixth of the matches
will combine those player ones and those
player twos if we had 10 player ones and
10 player twos there'd be some some
randomness and who gets matched with
whom so that's that's not the case here
so
we have a state of a system
how many players have seen each possible
sequence of terminal nodes and the
players have policies what they do
as a function of what they've seen
so then that tells us what the
prevailing distribution of play in each
population is look at all the player
ones and we say how many have each
history and for each history how do they
play and that generates
aggregate strategies for player ones
and now we can update our system we have
obvious agents we match them up
they play according to their policies
they update their histories
and since this is an overlapping
generations model some agents leave and
are replaced
okay so that's if you haven't seen these
this before this is a lot of um
abstraction so i'll take a pause for a
question if there are any
okay so the the
key
point of of all this
setup
is this system has steady states and the
steady states are what you think they're
the fixed points of the map
and
what this
system was set up to do was to have
steady states if you're familiar with
literature on fictitious play or smooth
fictitious play
these are systems that don't have steady
states they converge to steady states
asymptotically but the system is
changing and slowing over time
and that's
works well for analyzing dynamics in
static games
but when we want to talk about players
experimentation incentives in these um
extensive games we need to have a sense
of what they see when they experiment so
being able to embed our players in a
stationary overall world is very helpful
okay
so
the system has steady states
and
the deterministic steady states
so
the system would have been stochastic if
the
with a finite number of agents from
random matching we got rid of that
fine
still
just on information theoretic
considerations you might be puzzled how
can people be learning and have a steady
state but because if there's more and
more information
in society then
things don't seem stationary and the
reason is
that
with the overlapping generations model
departing agents take their information
with them so
agents are learning each period but some
agents are leaving with their taking
their information so the total
information in society is constant
and that's why steady states exist and
it's now these i you know interest of
time
i'm being you know a little vague and
whatever overlapping generation
structure is
some of the papers i'll tell you about
assumed the agents had fixed finite
lifetimes so people lived capital t
periods and got replaced
other papers assumed
agents had a geometric lifetime so each
period there's a probably gamma that the
agent continues to the next period
with the fixed finite lifetimes the
existence of
steady states is just a standard
finite dimensional fixed point problem
with geometric lifetimes players can
live arbitrarily long so a state space
is infinite dimensional
causes some
minor technical problems with the proof
that the result is still true
and intuitively
even though we have an infinite
dimensional state space very few agents
live a very long time
so the tails of the feasible states are
very thin
so in a sense this dimensional state
space
is similar to one there's five dimension
that's a technical background so
if
good
these are steady states what do they
look like
so if the agents have very short
lifetimes if agents play only once the
steady state is completely determined by
their prior agents come in
play best response to the prior and
leave that's not very interesting
in the limit as agents live longer and
longer
any steady state must be a
self-confirming equilibrium
but that's not the focus of this talk
today the focus today
is on
what we call patiently stable strategy
profiles
these are limits of stable profiles or
agents are long-lived
so they can get enough data for their
data to swamp their priors
and they're also patient
because myopic agents won't experiment
so the theorem
is that every patiently stable profile
is the nash equilibrium
and here's a very high level proof
sketch
long-lived agents learn the path of play
and they eventually stop experimenting
the option value from experimenting goes
away
which is why the stable steady states
must be self-confirming equilibria
if a steady state isn't actually a nash
equilibrium some player has a profitable
deviation they could do better by
changing their play
and we use the assumption that agents
have non-doctrinaire priors to show that
when
agents in the role this is the players
who can gain by deviant or patient they
will perceive a non-zero option value to
experimenting which contradicts the fact
they should stop
basically your prior said there's some
chance your opponents were playing this
other strategy that would make
deviating good um
if you get no evidence opposing that and
you're really patient then you should
try it and see and if they really are
playing that way you won't get evidence
that opposes it
okay
so that's
from a paper with dave levine back in
the 90s i want to move forward in time
on nash equilibrium is not sufficient
for patient stability
okay
so we want to derive refinements of nash
equilibrium from principles of optimal
experimentation
okay i'm going to skip this slide i'm
not feeling the time is going so well so
skip forward 15 years
2006
let's talk about simple games these are
games of perfect information
where no player moves more than once on
any path
and we show that for some non-doctrine
non-doctrinaire priors there is no off
path experimentation
so the players on the path of play do
experiment the players off the path to
play don't so we don't get backward
induction
but off path play isn't completely
arbitrary
nodes one step off the play are reached
infinitely often so people there know
what happens if they conform to the
strategy so play
one step off the path should be an s c e
self confirming equilibrium
so definition
a node is one step off the path of
strategy profile pi
if the node x isn't reached under pi
but it's an immediate successor of a
node that is reached so
one player can deviate once and make
this node be reached
and a profile pi is a sub game confirmed
nash equilibrium if it's a nash
equilibrium and if in each sub game
beginning one step off the path
the restriction of pi to the sub game is
self confirming in that sub game
and the theorem of this paper was that
in
generic and i'll skip the formal
definition
simple games
any pure strategy
subject confirmed equilibrium is path
equivalent to a patiently stable state
and
what's the idea well
the option value at a node
the amount you perceive you can gain by
not playing myopically is bounded by a
term
that's proportional to its objective
probability the note is reached so if
you have very little information what
happens if you deviate but you know you
only play every million years and you
finally get a chance to play
you don't have even though you would
learn a lot if you experimented with the
new action if you can't use that
information for a million years
it's not worth it okay so if you think
you're unlikely to be reached
you're
not going to experiment
and players are unlikely to mistakenly
think they're likely to be reached when
they're not
so they can be so it's patiently stable
limit it's a sequence of steady states
where players get more and more patient
and live longer and longer and there's
all along this path
along the sequence agents might not be
experimenting at all so we don't get
backwards induction as in this simple
example three player
centipede game
it's easy to solve by backwards
induction three should pass
getting two so one should pass to get
two instead of one
so player one should also pass so the
unique backwards induction sub being
equilibrium everyone passes
but the profile where one drops and two
drops and three passes
is a sub game confirmed equilibrium why
well
given that two drops
it's optimal for one to drop so it's a
nash equilibrium so one's playing
optimally
player two is dropping there should be
passing
so what player two is doing
is not optimal and we don't have a nash
equilibrium starting with player two
but dropping by player two
is self-confirming because player two
can drop thinking that player three
drops
and if player two never experiments and
gives three to move this is what he
really does player two won't learn that
three is making this mistake
okay
so the paper um
has a very cute title about the code of
hammurabi
and it argues that the sort of
incomplete off path learning can explain
the persistence of some superstitions
like those embodied in one of
hammurabi's codes
and i'll just remark on the side the the
theory model says these superstitions or
subgame confirmed equilibria can persist
forever now it's obviously an
idealization
the way i'd like you to think about
these results is that
superstitions or wrong beliefs that are
sub-game confirmed
can persist a lot longer for those that
aren't so if someone on the path of play
has the wrong belief then they can
experiment and find out that it's wrong
and that seems comparatively fragile
so you know
a norm um
you better
do what you're told or you're obstructed
by lightning um
isn't a very robust norm because a few
kids
decide to try and disadvantage what
happens they aren't extracted by
lightning thing unravels
but if the norm is um
don't accuse
the wrong people of the murders you saw
done
you never see you hardly ever see any
murders done so that's going to be a
superstition that's um much harder to um
to unravel it's okay
fine that's 2000s now i'm going to get
up to the previous decade
the 2010s
so in signaling games experimentation
incentives for the agents at least
partially validate traditional
refinements
consider a learning model
with uh
have these sender agents have types
the types don't change over time so the
certain fraction of high type agents
certain high types center certain
fraction of low type centers aggregate
mass constant equal to the prior
and suppose that the center's subjective
beliefs about the replies to different
signals is a product measure
so you can send different signals
the only way to learn about the
responsible given signal is to play it
you don't learn about the response to
one signal by taking a different signal
now types that are more likely to gain
by deviating put off past signal are
more likely to experiment with it
and receivers will learn this and that's
to constrain their replies and this is
something that kevin hoe and i captured
with the notion of type compatibility
the paper defines
a an order
of which types are more compatible with
each signal
it's based on the payoffs in the stage
game and the thing that i thought might
be of interest to
computer scientists like bandit's
problems is that we extend this ordering
on
types from the static game to the
learning model by using the optimal
stopping time of the kittens index
okay so
remember the getting this index is
defined
with respect to a stopping time that
maximizes your average discounted
return
until stopping
you can take that stopping rule
of the gittins
theorem
and take
the sender's belief over how people
respond to a signal
and any stopping time
for
using that signal induces a distribution
over
what we call discounted receiver actions
that you'll observe before stopping it's
like a discount of occupation measure of
what the receiver does
and we show that for each sender type
the expression that defines the gittins
index for a signal
is the same as the payoff against the
strategy induced by the stopping time
um
okay let's
it's vague but it gives you a flavor of
what we did so if these two types have
the same beliefs
and type theta prime is more compatible
with the signal than type theta double
prime
and type and signal s prime is the
highest kittens index for type theta
double prime it also has the highest
index for type theta prime
so if theta prime uses a given signal at
a given history
so to state a prime
but since the types have different
payoff functions they don't use the same
policy we don't know they see the same
histories but then we use a coupling
argument like that for the proof of the
gittins theorem
to show that in aggregate the more
compatible types play a given signal
more than less ones do and that
receivers learn this that gives us an
equilibrium refinement that's um
resembles the choke creps intuitive
return but is stronger
so
that paper did not
um
suppose that players know their
opponent's payer functions in particular
the players had non-doctrinaire priors
over opponents play that means you have
to assign positive probability that
everything your opponent could do
including playing dominated actions
so the second paper with kevin adds the
restriction
that players assign probably zero
to opponent strategies that are strictly
dominated
and that might seem very natural to you
but i'll point out
um
it's actually really only works in
special classes of games that here
in signaling games the receivers
have no reason to experiment
they're the last mover they see what the
sender does
and they you know
learn nothing different by changing
their action so the receivers won't play
strictly dominated strategies
and senders with independent beliefs
won't play dominated strategies either
but i'll show you an example soon of a
different game where senders will choose
to play dominated strategies so senders
can choose to play dominated strategies
in the learning model
and you build into people's priors
probably zero that people play dominated
strategies now you have a problem
because your players will see zero
probability events
not a problem signaling games we end up
with a more restrictive refinement
called rationally compatible equilibrium
and
one more of these recent papers um with
dan clark
studies a signaling game or in addition
to sending signals the senders can send
cheap talk messages so those of you who
are familiar with uh cho prep's paper
know there's an informal discussion of
senders making speeches
to the receivers but those speeches
aren't modeled in the game so here we're
making cheap talk and explicit move in
the extensive form game
and we're also going to assume unlike in
the other papers
in this literature
that there's an asymmetry in a lifetimes
that the senders play the game much more
often than receivers do
which means that most receivers only
interact with very old senders who've
already stopped experimenting
so that's you know a restrictive
assumption but it fits some settings we
argue it fits the settings with the
senders or firms or institutions who
interact with a large number of
individual receivers
and
here we're able to drop the assumption
of independent beliefs so
kevin and i needed the sender's
beliefs about different signals to be
independent in order to appeal to the
gittins index theorem here we're not
going to use kittens we don't need
independent beliefs
but we're going to have this assumption
of we call initial trust that that the
receivers there's at least some things
that
centers can say that receivers believe
the first time they hear it
if they hear it
if they've heard it and it's been alive
they stop believing it they're not
infinitely credulous but they're
initially trusting if
if the sender
sun sender makes a cheap talk message
and here we get yet another refinement
called justified communication
equilibrium okay
um
i took out this slide
but what i should tell you is that
both this justified communication
equilibrium and the
uh
rational
rationality compatible equilibrium
um look like classical refinements
they are
they
um
rule out
more sequential equilibria than the
intuitive criterion does but less than
colburn or 10 say
okay so let me just take stock of where
we were
up through the
end of last year in this literature
so the in the simple games i told you
about
sequential equilibrium predicts the
backward induction solution
so in a generic game it's a point so we
couldn't have hoped that learning would
make tighter predictions
in these simple games and in fact it may
makes much weaker ones
every sub-game confirmed equilibrium is
patiently stable
the other hand signaling games
have a great many sequential equilibria
typically
because of the freedom to specify what
the receiver believes
when they see a signal that's off the
equilibrium path
and patient learning can rule out some
sequential equilibria so in one class of
games patient learning is weaker in
sequential equilibrium and the other
class of games is stronger
so why the differences
well
signaling games are different than
simple games in two ways first of all
the relative probability of experiments
matter in the simple games all that
mattered is is this node reached or not
because every information set was a
singleton so the relative probabilities
experiments didn't matter
in
the signaling game
there can be multiple
types of sender who could all send the
same signals so the receiver sees the
signal it wasn't supposed to happen in
equilibrium they need to have some
belief about the relative probability of
different center types
and the level of probabilities of the
center uh
of the experimentation by the center so
it was what pinned it down okay
something i didn't say
um
and a nice thing i think of this
learning approach is
the classic you know you can show craps
the
off pass signal should never be set so
we were talking about how to update
after zero probably events and counter
factuals
in the learning model
young senders experiment so all these
off-pass signals are sent with some
small
probability that decreases as lifetimes
get long and players get patient
so but because they happen
we don't have to result to metaphysics
to decide on
their interpretation we just use bayes
rule so i think that's nice okay so
that's that's why the experimentation
probably matters in cycling games
the other hand signaling games have this
nice property receivers don't need to
experiment because they see centers type
regardless of what they do
and just denote how to unify these
things if we look at a simple game of
length two
the sub game confirmed is backwards
induction
and if we look at a signaling game with
a single center type then it is a simple
game of length two so we get the same
results from sequential equilibrium and
patient stability
in either
simple games of length 2 or degenerate
signaling games okay so finally um last
20 minutes
let me
talk about the uh
newest work i've been doing
on this topic and this is with dan clark
and kevin huss with the two co-authors
the earlier papers
and
we're looking at how
the learning program relates to the
classic literature on refinements
one
thing
that shows up a lot in this literature
is idea of normal form invariance
meaning
when should two extensive forms have the
same solution
what transformations of extensive form
should leave our predictions unchanged
so kolberg and martens argue for
that a good solution concept should
depend only on the reduced normal form
so that you've any two extensive forms
with the same reduced normal form you
should make the same predictions
and the reason they say this
because they argue this reduced normal
form
captures all the relevant information
for decision purposes
well
dan and kevin i think that's leaving
something out we think it i would say it
captures the relevant information
holding fixed your beliefs about the
play of your opponents
and that we only should expect the set
of learning outcomes to be invariant to
transformations that are decision
variant in the sense of clubbering
retends meaning they lead to the same
best responses
as a function of opponent strategies
but also
to have this invariance we want the
transformation to be information
invariant we should give the same
feedback to the agents to give agents
different feedback they'll learn
different things
so
good
what kind of invariances are there well
one invariants that kolberg returns are
you for
that reduced number form picks up and
that learning agrees with
is that
that it shouldn't matter if you split a
decision node so here i have two
different
representations of the same game where
player one can go out
in one or in two
and in one and then two give the move to
player two
so in the left hand game
play one is a single
three-part choice out in one or in two
in the right-hand game
player one first decides out or in
and then if player one goes in
player two sees that
and player one goes either one or two
which player two does not see
okay
now let's look at the sequential
equilibrium
of these games so i claim in the left
hand game
the outcome where player one goes out
and player two goes right this is
sequential equilibrium okay so out is
the best response to right because four
is more than two
and why is player two playing right well
because player two's beliefs at this off
path information set is that
they think they're probably at
one probably played in one
how do you make that work with
sequential equilibrium well we have to
specify this consistent belief so we
have to have some trembles for player
one where player one mostly plays out
and you know plays in one with probably
say epsilon in place n2 is probably
epsilon squared
and now
compute two's posterior and two things
one probably went in one and two plays
right so it's a sequential equilibrium
in the game on the left is that clear
on the other hand it's not in the game
on the right okay well the move started
with
one
playing one or two that sub game
that's a simultaneous move sub in
between one and two
and
in that sub game
action two
for player one
strictly dominates action one so player
one can't play
one
in the right hand game so two has to
play left so the only sequential
equilibrium in the right hand game is
in and then um
two and then player two plays left so
sequential equilibrium is not invariant
to splitting
um decision nodes
but the set of patiently stable outcomes
is
because player two gets the same
information player one's the same
information but player two in both cases
um
good
okay and in fact so this
out is patiently stable in both of these
games both the left-hand game and the
right-hand game
didn't matter how we wrote it
another
example of a difference um
the
transformations make so we can take any
perfect information game like that
three-player
centipede game
and
look at the associated normal form
and suppose that people display the
normal form
okay so we have this this game where
each player has
two choices
proper pass
they're playing the normal form they
play simultaneously the moves are
revealed
okay
so the players see each other's
actions
non-doctrinaire priors imply the player
threes will never pass because it's
weakly dominated
and unlike the extensive form if each
player writes down their move on a piece
of paper then they all hold pieces of
paper
then the term the terminal node of a
simultaneous in the game encodes all
three player strategies
to players actions so player twos don't
need to experiment to learn player
three's play
because the player threes aren't playing
pass twos will see it
and even if they initially thought that
three's dropped they see them passing
they'll eventually learn that threes
pass
so twos will start to pass
and then
with enough more data the player wants
to start to pass
so more generally if agents play the
normal form
corresponding to a simple game
then the patiently stable outcomes
do satisfy backwards induction so that's
a very simple way of seeing
that we don't have normal form
invariance because a normal form
doesn't have enough information to pin
down the result of learning
it has a decision relevant information
but if we want invariance
of learning outcomes
we need to replicate the feedback
players get
so
the way we propose doing that
is what we call a terminal node
partition
so for terminal node partition is that
if player one drops
players don't get to observe the choices
of players two and three
and if player 1 passes and player 2
drops
then players don't get to observe the
choice of
player 3.
so here's a
picture of this
simultaneous move game
with terminal note partitions added so
the usual the dashed lines between
um
the information set of player two means
player two can't tell if one dropped or
passed when player two moves
and the dashed line between the if sets
of player three player three can't tell
anything when they move so it's a one
shot simultaneously game just as i said
the new feature of this game
is the little smaller dots connecting
some of the terminal nodes on the bottom
of the graph and that's the terminal
node partition so you see the left hand
of the figure there's the four terminal
nodes all linked together if player one
drops all anyone else sees is that
player one dropped they don't get to see
what player two chose or player three
chose
and on the right hand side if play one
passes in two drops then people don't
get to see what player three would have
done
if two had passed
so this is a way of
preserving the information that's lost
when we move to the normal form
so this idea of trouble node partitions
isn't new
it's been used in past work to define
equilibrium concepts that were inspired
by learning
and what we're doing differently in our
paper is we're explicitly incorporating
these terminal partitions into the
learning models to see what happens
okay
one last
difference between
the predictions of our patient learning
models and classic refinements is how it
handles forward induction
so corporate mercens
and subsequent papers argue that
solution concepts should imply
the iterated deletion of weakly
dominated strategies or the related
concept of forward induction and i put
four induction in quotes because
people have a sense of what it means but
there's not one accepted definition
there's many
similar definitions in the literature
governor wilson colbert mortens
rennie and so on um
none of these definitions has been
accomplished by a theory
of how players
could come to have equal different
beliefs
or why they should maintain their
beliefs in equilibrium after a deviation
because one way of thinking of forward
induction you solve these mistakes
and you want to explain it in the way
consistent with everyone playing
equilibrium from now on and people
trying to be rational even though what
you've seen so far
didn't look like that
okay
so here's a simple example of the
of a difference between
learning models
and classical refinements it's a failure
forward induction
so
if they want to go out and get zero or
in one or in two
so the extensive form
on the left
and the normal form on the right
looking at the normal form on the right
it's very clear that out for player one
dominates in one you get its sure zero
this is sure negative one
so
what
colbert mertens's version of ford
induction would like us to do is say
whatever we predict
in this game should be the same
prediction as if we just crossed out
in one for player one because it's
dominated
they say stable set should contain a
stable set after removing a dominated
strategy
once we get rid of the row in one
then into and left is the only
sequential equilibrium
because if player one goes in two
but
given that player one can't go in one if
player one goes in player two knows it's
it's in two so player two plays left
so player one wants to go in
so fine
that's the answer from colebrook martens
what's the story from the learning model
well suppose
you're a player one
and you're gonna play this game
repeatedly
and you don't know what player two is
doing
and this
you think
probably player two
is playing
um right or playing right with high
probability point nine or something but
maybe
there's some chance that player two
um
typically plays left
if player two is playing left
more than half a time
in two's actually better for you
so but your prior is such that you're
better off playing outs if you're myopic
you play out but it's push your patient
then you might receive an information
value
of giving player two the move to see
what would happen
okay
but if you think player two is probably
playing right
then
playing in two
will give you a payoff of near negative
five maybe minus four an expectation
whereas playing in one only costs you
minus one
so
what you might want to do
is play in one a couple of times and see
what happens
and then if player two
indeed plays right as you expected you
stick
without but if player two turns out to
be playing left you'll switch to in two
now so it's a point here in this example
in one and in two
you have the same information about
player two's action
and
in one
gives higher static payoff
if
you think two is likely to play right
so we can we can and have written down
priors
under which
the
player one agents
um
when their newborn and perceived life
experimentation initially play in one a
bit
and then they learned that the twos were
playing
um right and they stop
so
in this overlapping generations model
there'll be a few young player ones
experimenting within one
mostly old player ones playing out
the player twos will be playing right
because they will have seen that
normally once go out but on the rare
occasions that the player ones go in
they're playing in one
so it's optimal then for the twos to
play right
so that can give you hopefully that
gives you a sense of why there's no
reason to expect
um rational learning models to give us
anything like
ford induction
in general games
okay
and wilson
um
are
um
trying to explain why forward induction
is a desirable property of a refinement
what we'd like our concepts to have for
induction they'll say if an outcome does
not satisfy ford induction
there's an equivalent game
in which this outcome results only from
nash equilibria
and not from any sequential equilibrium
and because they
um
support this idea of normal form
invariance
they view this as a problem that why
should we
take something where it's not a
sequential equilibrium in some
equivalent game of course from our
viewpoint the problem is
why are these equivalent normal forms
supposed to be played the same way
this comes back to the fact there's no
reason to expect normal form invariance
and the the
logic of one of the arguments in favor
to forward induction is this normal form
of variance and
forward induction on its own isn't
compatible isn't applied by learning
models and normal form and variance
isn't applied by learning models so it's
just a very different way of thinking
about equilibrium
so that's what
um
we done so far
let me just mention a few
what i think are interesting open
questions
so
i expect agents to learn the
consequences of actions and information
sets closer to the path of play they
take fewer people to deviate more
quickly the information sets farther
away
the subgame confirmed equilibrium is a
very stark version of that that people
learn the path of play people on the
path to play them one step off and then
nothing at all gets learned two or more
steps off and that just seems too stark
so
it'd be
interesting to see if there's
some
way formalizing the idea that players
have more information two steps off the
path than three and more three than four
and so on
another
open question so my paper with dan clark
to get a refinement for signaling games
with cheap talk
we assumed an asymmetry in interaction
rates but the senders played the game a
lot more than the receivers did
and we had a story for why that made
sense in the signaling games we were
studying but
are there other settings where
asymmetries
in the um interaction rates of different
populations have interesting consequence
interesting consequences
okay
the
work
i've told you so far
all has agents
whose priors
at least include the truth
as something they thought was possible i
mean
players can get stuck in steady states
where they have incorrect beliefs but
off past play but it's not because we
gave them a prior that forbid them to
learn what happened off path they just
didn't happen to get enough data
um
if players have incorrect beliefs about
the extensive form
then they're misspecified and they'll
actually be unable to learn what's
really going on
so that's
opens up an intersection between this
learning games
literature which has been assuming
correctly specified invasions
and a pretty large
recent body of work in economics on
bayesian agents with misspecified priors
so what would happen if we let people be
misspecified about the game and try to
go through some parts of a learning
games program we don't know
and then a um
natural question for computer science
audience you know so we used expected
discounted utility as our way
of deriving experimentation rates we
weren't happy with this arbitrary
assumptions um
and you know being economists this seems
like the natural
starting point
for analysis
but
it'd be interesting to extend this
program to agents who use other rules
for guiding their policies things like
upper confidence bounds which are
computationally simpler you know they
have a bit of the flavor
of
the expected
bit of a flavor programming solution not
quite the same so
the question is to what extent do
conclusions carry over
to these heuristics and what kind of new
things come up
that's i um
actually
managed to finish early because i was
radically trimmed of a notation
out of my slides so i hope that wasn't
too high level but i'm
happy to take questions now and thank
you very much
all right thanks a lot um let's see do
we have any questions in the audience
here
oh okay i can ask one question i guess i
was uh your third bullet was kind of
getting at this but um
yeah i guess like maybe you could just
say a little more about what
what is known kind of when you have
priors that are not necessarily like
fully supported
okay in the
um
learning in games
setting very little and that only for
myopic agents but there is um
some work on how
you can get um
you can explain things like shaheel's
analogy-based
uh
equilibrium
with certain kinds of
wrong models of the world
um
one reason
little known
i should say is that
the
the combination of misspecified beliefs
and non-myopia
makes things very complicated and
unexpected
um so that hasn't been studied in a game
setting but even in decision settings
it's known you can have a decision
problem
where
correctly specified
agents
their beliefs converge
whether or not they're patient
and where myopic agents beliefs converge
even if they're misspecified
but patient
and non but and mispathified agents
beliefs needn't even converge
um
okay so let me um
review this a bit so if you have
exogenous data and people are just
learning from exogenous data then it's
known from burke that beliefs converge
to the distributions in the prior that
minimize the kale diverges with the
truth
so if your prior allowed the truth
that's the minimizer and if not you pick
what
whatever corner points in the prior
comes closest
in extensive games or in many decision
problems the data you see depends on
your action so burke's result doesn't
really apply directly
and
it can if you have a patient miss
specified agent they might
play something for a while decide action
a is optimal and after playing action a
decide no i should go experiment with
action b
and then play action b and go back and
spread with action a so that's even just
the the question of when beliefs will
converge
in this setting seems complicated so
might have to
start by analyzing this just for myopic
agents i'd be happy to do that even that
has not been done very systematically i
mean imagine that you think you're
playing a simultaneous move game
with your opponent but really your
opponent gets to see your move
um
thanks yeah that's super interesting
um
i think we're a little over time now so
we should probably go to a break before
the next talk but why don't we uh thank
drew again
[Applause]
all right thanks all picky art
yeah we're really glad you could join us
um and yeah so we'll be back at 11 30
for uh amy greenwald stock okay i'll
i'll i'll be back here too then that
sounds good right
foreign